♪♪
>>> DEVELOPING OVERNIGHT, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATENING TO
INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE TO
BLOCK THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
THAT IS INVESTIGATING THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION FROM
OBTAINING A WIDE RANGE OF
DOCUMENTS THAT IT'S DEMANDING
FROM SEVERAL U.S. GOVERNMENT
AGENCY.
CNN'S WHITNEY WILD IS JOINING US
NOW.
THIS IS A BIG REQUEST.
HE WOULD HAVE REASON TO BE
CONCERNED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS REQUEST IS ABOUT 40 PAGES
LONG.
IT CONCERNS COMMUNICATIONS,
RECORDS THAT GO ALL THE WAY BACK
TO APRIL 2020 AND THE COMMITTEE
IS LOOKING AT AGAIN A WIDE RANGE
OF DECISIONS AND ACTIONS THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN MADE BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, PEOPLE
WITHIN HIS ORB AND THE CAMPAIGN.
HERE IS A SNAPSHOT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE POSSIBLY SUBJECTS IN
THIS INVESTIGATION.
NONE OF THOSE NAMES WOULD BE A
SURPRISE, MARK MEADOWS, TROUMP
LOYALIST ROGER STONE, MEMBERS OF
THE TRUMP FAMILY.
NONE OF THAT IS SURPRISING.
THE BREADTH OF THE SCOPE MIGHT
BE SURPRISING AND POSSIBLY WAS
TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PARTISAN
EXERCISE IS BEING PERFORMED AT
THE EXPENSE OF LONG-STANDING
LEGAL PRINCIPLES OF PRIVILEGE,
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE WILL BE
DEFENDED.
THESE DEMOCRATS HAVE ONLY ONE
TIRED TRICK, POLITICAL THEATER,
AND THEIR LATEST REQUEST ONLY
RE-ENFORCES THAT PATHETIC
REALITY.
HARSH WORDS.
IT IS ULTIMATELY NOW PRESIDENT
BIDEN WHO WILL HAVE THE ULTIMATE
SAY WHETHER THESE WHITE HOUSE
RECORDS ARE RELEASED.
WE HAVE SEEN A FEW SNIP PETS
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THIS REQUEST SPANS A WIDE RANGE
OF ACTIONS WHICH COULD INCLUDE
WHAT THE PRESIDENT KNEW ABOUT
THE ELECTION, EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION, EFFORTS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION MADE TO
REMOVE KEY PLAYERS AND KEY
AGENCIES AND INSERT TRUMP
LOYALISTS AND WHAT HAPPENED ON
THE DAY OF THE RIOT, THAT
INCLUDES POSSIBLY -- AT LEAST
REQUESTING WE DON'T KNOW IF
WE'LL GET THEM OUTTAKES FROM THE
VIDEO HE POSTED TELLING THE
RIOTERS TO EVENTUALLY GO HOME.
>> MEANING THEY WANT THE ONES
THAT DIDN'T GET POSTED.
>> RIGHT.
THEY WANT WHAT'S ON THE CUTTING
ROOM FLOOR.
>> INTERESTING.
SO WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES ON
CNN LAST NIGHT.
HERE IS WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY.
>> WE ARE TRYING TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED LEADING UP TO THE
JANUARY 6th, THE VARIOUS
ELEMENTS, THE REASONING, WHO
INSTEAD GATED IT, WHY THEY INSTA
GATED IT AND THE LIKE.
WE WANT TO FIND OUT EVERY
ELEMENT OF IT AND SO WE'VE MADE
THIS REQUEST AND THIS IS, AS I
SAID, JUST THE BEGINNING.
>> WELL, SHE'S RIGHT.
SO IN THOSE DOCUMENT REQUESTS
THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS
JUST THE START OF WHAT WILL BE A
ROLLING REQUEST FOR DOCUMENTS.
THIS MAY SET UP A LENGTHY LEGAL
BATTLE.
TRUMP COULD TRY TO GO TO COURT.
WE KNOW IT'S PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
THE ULTIMATE SAY OVER THE WHITE
HOUSE RECORDS AND WITH REGARDS
TO EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND
BRIANNA ALL OF THIS IS SUPPOSED
TO BE DUE BY SEPTEMBER 9th.
SO WE'LL SEE.
>> NO PROBLEM.
THAT'S COMING UP FAST.
WHITNEY WILD, THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT.
>>> JOINING ME NOW ELIE HONIG, A
FORMER STATE AND FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS IN
IN-DEPTH.
WHAT HAS THIS COMMITTEE DONE SO
FAR?
>> JOHN, THEY'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK SO FAR.
THE STAKES COULDN'T BE HIGHER.
THEY BEGAN WHEN THEY CALLED THIS
HEARING WITH D.C. AND CAPITOL
HILL POLICE OFFICERS.
ONE MOMENT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS WHEN THIS OFFICER
SAID THIS TO THE COMMITTEE, YOU
GUYS ARE THE ONLY ONES WE'VE GOT
TO DEAL WITH CRIMES THAT OCCUR
ABOVE US.
I NEED YOU GUYS THE COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS IF ANYONE IN POWER HAD A
ROLE IN THIS.
BENNY THOMPSON, REPRESENTATIVE,
WHO IS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR, SAID
HE'S WILLING TO DO JUST THAT.
HE SAID ANYBODY WHO HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE AND OFFICIALS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, WHILE THE INVASION OF THE
CAPITOL WAS GOING ON IS DIRECTLY
IN THE INVESTIGATIVE SIGHTS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND
REPRESENTATIVE THOMPSON SAID
HE'S GOING TO PLAY HARDBALL.
I HAVE NO RELUCTANCE IN ISSUING
SUBPOENAS FOR INFORMATION.
>> WHITNEY OUTLINED SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THIS MAY INCLUDE AND MA
TYPES OF THINGS ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT?
>> REALLY BROAD.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
ON JANUARY 6th THE LOGICAL PLACE
TO START IS DONALD TRUMP.
THAT SAID, IS CONGRESS GOING TO
WANT THAT CIRCUS?
I'M DOUBTFUL.
HOWEVER, MARK MEADOWS IN TOUCH
WITH TRUMP THAT DAY.
JARED KUSHNER.
AND THIS IS WHERE IT'S GOING TO
GET REALLY INTERESTING, TWO
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE, McCARTHY
AND JIM JORDAN BOTH ADMITTED
TALKED THAT THEY HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH DONALD TRUMP
ON THAT DAY.
ALSO, WE KNOW THE COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO GO OUT AND GET PHONE
RECORDS, KEY COMMUNICATIONS AND
BRINGING ME BACK TO MY
PROSECUTOR DAYS.
THIS IS WHAT A SAMPLE PHONE
RECORD FROM VERIZON WILL LOOK
LIKE.
IT WILL TELL YOU WHAT NUMBER IS
MAKING THE CALL.
WHAT NUMBER IS RECEIVING THE
CALL EXACTLY WHAT DATE AND TO
THE SECOND WHAT TIME THAT CALL
WAS MADE AND FINALLY OVER HERE
HOW MANY SECONDS LONG THAT CALL
WAS.
SO THIS IS GOING TO TELL YOU WHO
WAS IN TOUCH WITH WHO IN THOSE
KEY MOMENTS LEADING UP TO AND
DURING AND AFTER THE ATTACK.
FINALLY, WE KNOW THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN VERY BROAD REQUESTS FOR ALL
THESE FEDERAL AGENCIES.
THE ONE THAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING TO ME IS THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
YOU MAY BE THINKING, WHY THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES?
THAT'S WHERE THE PARCHMENT COPY
OF THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE ARE.
THEY HAVE THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
RECORDS.
>> SO EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP LAST
NIGHT IN AN ANGRY INTERNET
STATEMENT SAYS HE'S GOING TO
DEFEND EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHO ACTUALLY GETS TO DECIDE
HERE?
>> IT'S SUCH AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
CONVERSATIONS ARE PRIVILEGED
DON'T HAVE TO BE TURNED OVER TO
CONGRESS CAN BE HELD BACK.
THE BIG QUESTION IS WHO GETS TO
EXERCISE IT?
IS IT THE CURRENT PRESIDENT?
OR IS IT THE PRESIDENT WHOSE
RECORDS AND COMMUNICATIONS THEY
WERE.
WHITNEY ALLUDED TO THIS, WE
DON'T HAVE A DEFINITIVE ANSWER
BUT THE BETTER WEIGHT OF THE LAW
AND PRECEDENT IS THAT IT'S UP TO
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT JOE BIDE
N.
IF THE HOUSE FLIPS IN A YEAR AND
CHANGE, THEY COULD THROW THAT
BACK IN HIS FACE.
OF COURSE, DONALD TRUMP HAS SAID
HE'S GOING TO INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
HE WILL LOSE IF HE TRIES TO
FIGHT IT IN COURT.
HE WILL MAKE IT A MESS AND HE
WILL DRAG IT OUT.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS GOING TO COURT ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER WHICH MEANS IT WON'T
BE DECIDED ANY TIME SOON I
IMAGINE.
>> EXACTLY.
TAKING A STICK AND PUTTING IT IN
THE SPOKES OF THE WHEEL.
IF DONALD TRUMP CAN OBSTRUCT BY
GOING TO COURT GIVEN HIS HISTORY
I LOOK FOR HIM TO TRY TO DO
THAT.
>> ONE OTHER THING, PROTECTING
CONVERSATIONS WITHIN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, JIM JORDAN NOT
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
>> THAT WOULD BE AN
UNPRECEDENTED EXPANSION OF THE
PRIVILEGE.
THEY'RE PART OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE PRIVILEGE.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN THE TRUMP
ADMI